bonjour françois bayrou alexis tsipras
se présente donc sa copie aujourd'hui
nous y sommes êtes vous optimiste ou
inquiet ce matin je ne suis pas
optimiste et qui pourrait l'être dans
les circonstances je suis inquiet pour
la grèce et pour nous parce que la
sortie de la grèce de la zone euro sera
évidemment quoi qu en dise un certain
nombre de partisans sera une catastrophe
pour les grecs mais une catastrophe dont
on touchera le la gravité en termes de
de misère de blocage du pays d'extrême
difficulté et en même temps ce sera pour
nous forcément une onde de choc
tous ceux qui croient comme françois
hollande l'a dit que nous sommes à
l'abri de toute contagion de toute
difficulté à mon sens se trompe
gravement
parce que quand le feu se met dans une
pièce de la maison de la maison euros et
bien ce feu évidemment risque de se
propager d'une manière ou d'une autre à
toute la maison
alors chacun y va de son conseil 1
écoutez moi je vous propose de pierre
moscovici c'était tir soir sur france
info avec jean leymarie il dit pierre
moscovici commissaire ces réformes
doivent être convaincante il ya
également la directrice générale du
fonds monétaire international madame
christine lagarde
la grèce doit avoir une dette viable on
a l'impression que on est toujours dans
le même système on à la grèce d'un côté
on a la trouille cas de l'autre on est
dans le système des voeux pieux avec une
assez grande hypocrisie parce que on a
l'impression qu'un très grand nombre de
dirigeants européens en réalité sont
résignés au pire est que il est c'est
une chose c'est de ne pas apparaître
comme les responsables d'envoyer la
patate chaude à d'autres mais on a
l'impression que le scénario est écrit à
l'avancé
je pense que si l'on voulait trouver une
note d'espoir alors on voit bien ce
qu'il faut faire d'une part il faut
rééchelonner retarder les remboursements
de la dette pour la grèce sans supprimer
cette dette
deuxièmement il faut que la grèce
présente des réformes organise chez elle
avec le soutien des autres pays
européens
des réformes qu'ils soient des réformes
convaincante par exemple il n'ya pas de
cadastre en grèce 1 un cadastre avec des
satellites toute l'europe sait le faire
en quelques mois il n'y a pas de
récupération des impôts et vous voyez
bien les conséquences que cela peut
avoir en réalité il ya un suisse cube
les tories qu'il ya un état pléthorique
et tout ça c'est c'est tout à fait tout
à fait facile à organiser et à faire de
ce point de vue là on est si on le
voulait devant un programme qui pourrait
être un programme réaliste à condition
que l'aide des autres pays européens
pour réaliser les réformes
pas seulement pour donner de l'argent
parce que donner de l'argent c'est un
puits sans fond et donc c'est comme
disaient les grecs d'autrefois les grecs
de l'antiquité saisine tonneau des
danaïdes
celui que vous avez beau essayer de
remplir ce vide de toute façon vous
voulez dire qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait
une sorte de main tendue de d'assistance
de l'europe et non pas cette punition ce
soupçon ce discours punitifs aux
faudrait qu'il y ait une volonté et il
faudrait que les dirigeants aux hommes
moi je trouve pas il faudrait que les
dirigeants européens comprenne une bonne
fois pour toutes que nous sommes sur le
même bateau ils ont l'impression où il
donne l'impression que la grèce est dans
une situation politique différente de la
nôtre que cet autre chose que ce qui
arrive en grève nous ne nous atteindra
pas forcément nous aurons nous subirons
des conséquences négatives de ce qui va
se passer en grèce parce que la zone
euro était jusqu'à maintenant et c'est
cette idée très importante la zone euro
était jusqu'à maintenant une zone de
confiance pour le monde on pouvait
prêter à la zone euro avec un sentiment
de sécurité qui faisait que les taux
d'intérêt étaient bas et puis maintenant
on va s'apercevoir que si un pays de la
zone euro fait faillite
alors la zone euro ne protège de rien et
vous allez voir la défiance vous allez
voir le doubs
le soupçon envahir la zone euro ce qui
est une catalane au miel et la
fragilisation au niveau international et
la fragilisation et la de la faute de la
grèce pas seulement 2,6 presse mais
aussi des gouvernements précédents
alors monsieur de sipera s'il a fait
quelque chose qui est à mon sens grave
c'est à dire qu'il a promis il a
multiplié les promesses intenables et
ses promesses on va arriver devant la
circonstance ou un peu le lot de tous
les pardons de simple cliché mais c'est
le lot de tous les politiques qui sont
eux mêmes parfois en campagne il vient
je ne reprendra pas cela il y à des
politiques qui disent la vérité au lieu
de raconter des histoires et qui essaie
de partager avec le peuple des citoyens
qui va les élire ou qui doit les élire
une idée nette de la vérité parce que
seule la vérité permet de s'en sortir et
donc on va se trouver dans la situation
où la grèce
premièrement va se retrouver dans une
situation de chaos
il y aura plus de banques il y aura plus
de moyens il va falloir et imprimer de
la monnaie artificielle ou nouvelles ça
va être de ce point de vue là chaotique
et le chaos en poly le chaos en histoire
ça finit toujours en violences donc on
va se trouver dans cette situation là et
la zone euro va être fragilisés au total
c'est un énorme gâchis par les critiques
fusent déjà avant même le terme de cette
affaire le président de la république
mette en péril les négociations c'est ce
que dit françois fillon
dans le figaro ce matin la droite et le
centre françois bayrou critique le
présent à publique françois hollande en
lui reprochant de ne pas avoir tenu de
deux lignes claires dans la gestion de
la crise grecque vous êtes d'accord avec
ça vous a je critique françois hollande
d'avoir été aux yeux des français ou
auprès des français absent pendant la
période que nous venons de vivre il n'y
a pas eu enfin c'est la plus grave crise
que l'europe et l'euro et rencontré
depuis qu'ils existent
on va se trouver devant un pays qui va
peut-être ou qui risquent de quitter la
zone euro est peut-être l'union
européenne
c'est une crise majeure est ce que le
président de la république s'est adressé
aux français
est ce qu'il leur a parlé est ce qu'il
leur a indiqué ce qu'étaient les risques
les chances leur at-il dit quelle était
la position de la france parce que on a
l'impression que de ce point de vue là
en tout cas la position de la france est
les six n'ont pas défini du moins
dissimulé que nous jouons la diplomatie
dans les couloirs or lorsqu'on est dans
une zone démocratique ou dans un pays
démocratique il y a pour le président de
la république celui qui a la charge du
pays
le devoir le devoir de voir d'expression
exprimé auprès des citoyens pour
partager avec eux la vision de l'avenir
et de ce point de vue là oui françois
hollande mérite des critiques sévères
lorsque l'assemblée nationale ouakam à
se prononcer par un vote blague tout ça
c'est ce sont des débats artificiels
vous voyez bien que tout est joué on est
en train de vivre les dernières minutes
de cet acte décisif du drame grec est
rien et explicite et aux français qui
s'inquiètent contrairement à ce qu'on
croit faut pas imaginer que les français
se désintéressent de 7,2 cette affaire
ils en parlent ils y réfléchissent parce
qu'ils sentent bien que d'une manière ou
10e en relisant les français sont en
danger aujourd'hui enfin les peuples par
l'europe les peuples
ouais parle d'europe ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que le référendum grec
a été un quiproquo évidemment le
référendum grec
monsieur de sipera sadi voter non c'est
pour mieux rester en europe
évidemment c'est un abus de confiance et
donc tout cela forme
en effet un moment historique d'où le
président de la république ne s'est pas
avancé aux yeux des français pour dire
quelle direction nous allons suivre
encore un nom quelque chose s'est brisé
des d'ores et déjà au sein de l'union
européenne
en europe ce maillot ah c'est une crise
c'est une fracture qui est
extrêmement grave extrêmement lourdes et
qui va avoir des conséquences de long
terme pour la grèce évidemment qui va
entrer dans une zone de d'extrême
risques et pour les autres pays
européens est en tout cas pour les pays
européens endettés et c'est là qu'on va
vérifier que la dette que beaucoup de
d'observateurs présenté comme quelque
chose de léger et de sans gravité ça
vous enlève votre indépendance et ça
vous empêche de vivre et vous
reconnaîtrez là un thème que pour ma
part sur lequel pour ma part je me suis
battue depuis longtemps une petite note
positive de donner la parole à guy
birenbaum
vous aimez le tour de france on en
parlait tout à l'heure ils n'ont pas sa
peau enfin il est vous voyez une journée
de repos à pau et la journée de repos et
le tour s'arrête quatre jours à pau cas
vous inauguré lundi prochain pour un
étonnant site baptisé le tour des géants
assez simple une centaine de totem des
sculptures numérique à la gloire des
dirigeants du tour oui c'est c'est la
première fois qu'un mémorial en france
va être édifié ce étrange de souffrance
dans la ville même où le tour a fait le
plus souvent est une des villes où le
tour a fait le plus souvent étape est en
tout cas dans la ville mythique puisque
c'est à pau qu'avant les pyrénées où
après les pyrénées
très souvent le tour connaît un acte
décisif
et alors en effet il y aura là un une
sculpture interactive avec de la vidéo
qui va être une sculpture pour chacun
des vainqueurs ils seront nombreux pour
inaugurer ce site est pour chacun des
tours on va raconter chacun des tours de
france des 103 tours de france et chaque
année le vainqueur de l'épreuve viendra
inaugurer le totem qui immortalisera son
exploit vous pourriez presque faire la
même chose est claire les présidents la
public à présidentielle fait ça serait
ça serait peut-être moins amusant ou en
tout cas moins - géant
merci sur le tour de france et des
gérants de la route et on aimerait qu'il
y ait davantage de géant parmi les
présidents de la république si françois
bayrou